NARRATOR: Ancient
suggest that Earth may have
acted as a laboratory in which
extraterrestrials experimented
with various lifeforms,
and as evidence point to
the numerous ancient stories
of hybrid creatures.
Hybrid creatures
abound in mythology.
All over the world, we get
animals that are partly
one thing, partly another.
In ancient Greek, we
hear about the cerberus,
a terrifying
three-headed dog who
was the guardian of the
portal to the underworld.
The Greeks also
had the centaur--
half human, half horse, a
large and impressive creature.
In Hindu mythology, we
have the [non-english]..
These are strange-looking
characters,
serpentine at the bottom, human
torsos and heads and faces.
Even in the Koran,
the horse that
was said to have flown Mohammad
from Mecca to Jerusalem
was a flying horse
with a human face.
Either it's all
fantasy or our ancestors
witnessed these things.
And if they witnessed them,
there's two options to that.
Either these creatures
actually came
here, or whatever
extraterrestrials
were here created them.
And it's a huge, huge question,
because both possibilities,
in my opinion, are possible.
NARRATOR: If the hybrid
creatures described
in ancient mythologies really
did exist alongside humans
and other intelligent
hominids, is it possible
that Charles Darwin's
theory of natural selection
played a role in the
rise of humans after all?
Could it be a case of
alien intervention on Earth
creating numerous
species that were then
forced to fight for survival?
Perhaps further
clues can be found
by examining stories of an
ancient cataclysm, often
referred to as the Great Flood.
The Bible teaches
us an ancient legend
that there was a global flood.
We all know that the
sins of the people
would cause God to intervene.
But yet the legends tell us
that the actual problem that
occurred at this time was an
extraterrestrial involvement
and manipulation
of human genetics.
The Bible speaks in Genesis,
chapter 6 of the sons of God
who came down from
heaven and took
the daughters of men
as wives from which
were born a race of titans--
[non-english] is
the Hebrew word--
and that they unleashed terror
and havoc upon the world
The books of Enoch teach
us that these sons of God
were the angels who
came down from heaven.
The development was
going the wrong direction,
and then they decided to start
the whole experiment again.
They decided to
create a great flood.
We have stories
of the Great Flood
practically all over the world--
not only in the Bible, not
only in the Gilgamesh epic,
not only in the Enuma
Elish from the Sumerian.
We have it in Central
America among the Mayans.
We have it in South America
among the Kogi Indians
that lived in Colombia.
Always the Great Flood story.
But in every case, there
was a so-called god
who gave instructions
to construct a ship.
And this is where ancient
legends get very interesting.
Because while Noah was building
his ark and saving his animals,
other legends say that
others of his generation
took other precautions, some
building other types of ships
which were to go to the stars.
And what is also interesting
is that the legends
tell us that not all animals
were included on Noah's Arc.
NARRATOR: Does the
story of the Great Flood
provide evidence that
extraterrestrials have been
experimenting with
different lifeforms on Earth
for thousands of years?
Ancient astronaut
theorists suggest
that such experimentation
continues to this day,
but that it is now being
directed by humans.